And everybody, Dr. Kevin Cutters here, we're going to talk about the COVID-19 virus that
everybody's concerned about right now, the coronavirus, SARS and cancer.
We're talking about some kind of threads as I was digging through some research here, trying
to solve some problems for patients and for everybody that's worried about this.
Actually, Dr. Holder had sent me this really cool article from R&D Systems that talked
about, it was just published in December of 2019, about ACE2 receptors.
So ACE2 receptors is typically, we talk about ACE2 receptors in the endothelial cells.
Those are the cells that surround your arteries.
And we talk about them mainly for high blood pressure.
That's what ACE inhibitors do.
So ACE inhibitors inhibit this receptor so that the muscles, the smooth muscles,
that are just outside of the endothelial cells don't contract.
And that's what causes high blood pressure.
But what they're finding is that the coronavirus as well as the SARS viruses,
they're very similar viruses in the same family structure, use that ACE receptor
to enter into the body, not to enter into the cells but enter into the body.
And that's the first line of defense that is to figure out how to block the SARS and COVID using the ACE2 receptors.
This article is very well researched and you can look it up and it's quite interesting information
we're going to look at a few of the paragraphs from this article.
So this initially talks about what the coronavirus is.
It is a virus, very small virus.
All these viruses really started with animals as the initial host.
All these, the SARS and the corona started with bats.
And then the secondary host with the SARS and corona virus were a little bit different.
I think they're believing right now that the corona virus secondary host was snakes.
Maybe it was SARS that was snakes, I don't know.
There's different hosts and these are all due to the human species.
So that's why they are very violent and can spread quite easily because we really don't have antibodies for these viruses.
We've never been exposed to them.
But some interesting things that, as you look at this article, I talked about the ACE2 receptor as it's a receptor in.
Not just in your endothelial cells, but you have these receptors through your body.
It's part of your redded eduotension, eduotension system, the RAS system.
We talk a lot about that with cancer.
But certainly it's, it's mainly spoken about with hypertension.
Because again, you have a affinity toward that receptor increases the toad of the smooth muscles underneath the endothelial and causes an increase in blood pressure.
Now that's a normal thing that has to take place when you're under stress or you're running or you're exercising your blood pressure goes up, you're activating those ACE2 receptors.
But we don't want those cuts of the activated and that would cause high blood pressure on a resting state.
So that's where ACE inhibitors come in to inhibit that connection with that receptor so that we decrease the blood pressure.
So initially when the research was done on ACE2 with SARS was that they thought they could use ACE2 inhibitors.
That would, you know, just the same thing that they use for high blood pressure that would decrease the SARS and the coronaviruses from attaching to and using those receptors.
But it was found that it doesn't work that way using high blood pressure medication does not help prevent the virus.
And they dug some little deeper and they found out that there is, they tested some different drugs or there in the process of testing the drugs.
Again, this article was published in December, 2019 so very recently.
This drug, the TNPR SS wanted SS2 blocks the SARS COVID entry.
So it blocks the entry of the virus by you by blocking that dislodging that receptor.
So here's a good picture that they showed of this. Here's the virus itself using that ACE2 receptor to get into the body through the bloodstream and get into the body
and then affect the person. Well, they found that initially it thought again that ACE2 inhibitors would inhibit this and block this, it didn't work.
And they found that anti ACE2 antibodies did work and that's the drugs that they're trying, at least one class of the drugs that they're trying to create to help prevent this virus from really attacking this person and getting into the person.
So as I go down this rabbit trail and you start going, are there natural anti ACE2 antibodies, natural things that work as an ACE2 antibodies instead of looking at the drug that they're looking at.
So most of the studies that you look at, if you're digging into studies to try to solve a problem, most of the studies that are done are funded by pharmaceutical companies.
So of course they're looking for pharmaceutical novel pharmaceutical things that can be developed and patent to use this medication against diseases, which is great. That's what we want.
But what we're looking for is are there things that are already created by God that do the same thing or very similar things that we could use to solve the same problem.
So as you dig into anti ACE2 antibodies in the natural world, you come across some different articles.
Here's an article that's not even a real new article is in the American Society of Microbiology, Journal of Birology, about novel inhibitors of severe acute respiratory syndrome, coronavirus.
And I understand there's multiple different types of coronavirus. And this is very well researched. This is just one page of the references. There's actually I think 7576 references in this article. So it's a very well researched article.
But the three distinct mechanisms. Well, here's the mechanism that they found the drug that they tested. Here's a drug that they tested here.
This is the SSAA drug that they found that could inhibit the cat Epson L enzyme. So cat Epson L is an enzyme that's normal in your body that does certain things and degrades different proteins for a purpose.
But what they found is that the way that this mechanism works for blocking the coronavirus and the SARS virus from entering the body at the ACE2 receptor,
and the reason why ACE inhibitors don't work is that it really functions on this enzyme. So it inhibits the enzyme and it's the inhibition of the enzyme that where these drugs could actually function.
So then you go, okay, well, understanding this cat Epson L enzyme, what it does and how it could be inhibited, is start following down this rabbit hole. So please follow me with this. So this cat Epson L inhibitors start searching for cat Epson L inhibitors and you find some really interesting articles that are out there.
Here's an article from 2014 that shows try turpinolines. Now turpines, that might be a familiar word for many of my listeners. We talk about turpines and the benefit of turpines in all sorts of things. A lot of the herbs, the way the herbs work, have to do with the turpines that are naturally in the herbs.
So turpines are part of nature's system that could help with a lot of health. So a try turpinoid is a very unique type of turpine.
So they found in this article they tested 14 different try turpinolines or 14 different turpinolines and they found that the try turpinolines actually worked as cat Epson L and cat Epson B inhibitors.
And it was really interesting that among the 14 co-pulls evaluated it says right here, the most promising were these few right here. And I highlighted in red this one olionic acid because this is the one that we can find in nature.
So this one was found as a very good cat Epson L inhibitor. So again, going down this rabbit hole, what blocks the coronavirus and SARS from entering into the body.
Well, one of the things can be anything that could be an inhibitor to cat Epson L. These are some of the drugs that they're trying to develop right now.
So then you start digging. What are some natural inhibitors took of Epson L? How do you find that these try turpinolines? And this one in particular we're going to talk about is a good natural inhibitor of the concept of L enzyme.
So where do you find this specific try turpinolines olionic acid? Try turpinolines. Well, in the leaves of the Japanese low-quot tree contain a very precious substance called olionic acid. Here we are.
It also contains a mignoline, which is very interesting. And in particular, this is a solid acid. These are penta cyclic try turpines. So here's our turpines again, these try turpines.
Small amounts of which are also found in rosemary, apple peel, holy basil and sage. So again, a lot of herbs have these try turpinolines in them.
Well, our solid acid and its isomer on the olionic acid are chemically almost identical. They're structured differently only in the position of the methyl group.
Both offer potentially important health benefits such as preventing the development of cancer, inhibiting existing tumor cells, the growth of tumor cells, protecting against the side effects of chemotherapy and radiotherapy, and exerting anti-inflammatory, antioxidant, antiviral activity.
Well, how does it affect us with anti-viral activity by blocking that ACE2 receptor? That's where the coral virus and the SARS enter the body.
So our solid acid extracted from the leaves of the Japanese low-quot tree are shown to prevent the progression of cancer, promote muscle growth.
And this is probably prior to all of this. This is probably the primary reason that this is even made into a supplement because bodybuilders tend to use the aerosolic acid to help promote muscle growth.
Now, I think from a cancer clinic perspective, you start thinking, wow, with cakexia issues with loss of muscle density, with patients that are in later stage cancer, this could be a great addition to help with cakexia promotes muscle growth.
It also has showed anti-aging effects. And of course, what we're talking about in this little discussion is the antiviral effects.
So this product contains precious substances that we talked about, and you can find a bit of other things too.
Interesting stuff. So this our solid acid has traditionally been used for skin repairs, from an herbologist's point of view, to repair damaged tissues and the cutaneous barrier or the sculpt.
So any wounds, wound healing that protects the skin from photo-aging, from the sun and aging of the skin.
It's a potential inhibitor elastase, which is an enzyme present in the skin, so it helps with skin breakdown. So you have tighter skin, so that's kind of nice. So it's used for anti-aging purposes.
But it's also, we talked about the antiviral effects, especially with herpes virus, adenovirus, adenovirus, adenovirus, the coronovirus, SARS, the inhibition of the enzyme, catapsid L.
So recent studies on rats have indicated that it's inhibitory power, human lucocyte elastase for treatment of inflammatory lung disease, such as H1H1 and SARS.
It also has antimicrobial effects, so it can be beneficial for possibly tuberculosis and potential for treatment for Alzheimer's because it inhibits the breakdown of the enzyme acetyl colon esterase.
And acetyl-colyte is what's eaten up in the brain and diminished with Alzheimer's patients because one of the theories is because it excess amounts of this enzyme that breaks down acetyl-colyte.
So if you can block the enzyme that breaks down acetyl-colyte, you'll preserve acetyl-colyte in the brain and push out Alzheimer's.
So this is kind of a deep supplement and it could be a really cool addition to a lot of people.
Here is the supplement itself that we get. You can get this, the persalic acid in, it is in holy basil, so if you are a typically holy basil is used as an adeptogen,
it's in a few other things that I mentioned too, but it's very small percentage, so we'll talk about that.
You can read about this and I want to just read my slides, but it does block inflammatory cox2 pathways.
It can block the differentiation of the TH17 cells, so it helps with inflammatory cytokines.
That's where it can really help with chemotherapy and radiation patients in the ill effects of that.
It also neutralizes NF-caphabata, we talk a lot about that, and other cancer slides in NF-caphabata is a huge inflammatory marker that is upregulated with a lot of cancer patients, so if we could block that, that could be very beneficial.
So just talking about it, not even with the coronavirus or SARS, but talking about it as a cancer benefit.
This is a huge product that we're really excited to just add to our arsenal.
Now I said the beauty of this product here is that it's content of the amount of arsenic acid in it, so each capsule has 50 milligrams of arsenic acid.
Now it says 300 here because it's recommended to daily doses of six capsules, but if you look at a holy basil, if you have a holy basil product at home, it has only about 2.5 milligrams.
That's what I found on the market was I was searching for a good product, it only has about 2.5 milligrams of arsenic acid in it.
So you're talking about 2.5 per capsule or 50 per capsule. It's a huge difference.
And the beauty is this isn't even an expensive product. I think we have it on our store for, I think, it's $29 for 90 capsules.
So if you took three a day for $29, it's a great help for those people that have cancer to help slow the progression of their cancer.
We're going to start using a lot of our patients and as a preventative for viruses.
So you talk about a viral preventative or what do I want to do to help boost my immune system and hopefully prevent some issues with different viruses that are out there.
I would say this is a good addition. We're going to add this to our adult immune boosting bundle.
Now we go a little bit deeper at this because remember that TMTRSS2 inhibitor that we're searching for,
we have a lot of evidence of COVID-19 therapy in the first article.
We talked about anti-AZ2 antibodies and then also additionally this great big long word here inhibitors trying to block that pathway.
This right here is actually a gene. There's a gene for the TMTRSS2 that makes a certain protein that if we can inhibit that protein, we can help block the SARS COVID entry into host cells.
So the anti-AZ2 antibodies block the SARS COVID enter into the body.
But this inhibitor, if we can inhibit that gene for making a protein, we can block the SARS COVID entry into the host cells.
Well, what does this gene do? If you look this up, look up this information, it actually codes a protein for the expression of certain energy receptors.
So interesting, this ties back to my talk on prostate cancer and the new studies that are coming on on prostate cancer with energy receptor three.
So if we could use different products that help block those energy receptors, this is a theory here, could we help block the virus from entering into the cells?
Because that's really the goal. We don't want the virus to get inside of the cells because when a virus does what it enters our cells,
is it hijacks our cells mechanisms to just start pumping out more viruses? So it just starts reproducing and reproducing, that's when a person starts to really get sick.
So you're infected by this virus, it gets into our body through the bloodstream and gets into our cells through another mechanism through these energy receptors.
And then once it's inside the cell, then it starts hijacking our system and reproducing, reproducing, reproducing.
So if we could prevent it any way along that pathway, in the more that we can prevent it, the less problem that we're going to have from this.
So even though maybe all of us are going to be exposed to the coronavirus within the next couple of months, maybe 100% of us are.
So if we could decrease the amount of people that are going to get really sick from it, that's what the goal is.
So that is related to the energy receptor, energy receptor, the AR receptor. Besides having high affinity to testosterone are used by other substances.
So receptors are used by other substances and what viruses do to get into our body, there's no virus receptors on our cells.
So they hijack other receptors to get into the cell.
So this is one of the receptors that they hijack as the energy receptor, SARS and the COVID virus groups.
And it's believed that the virus utilizes the energy receptor to enter the cell.
So novel use of energy receptor blockters may prove to help limit the virulence of the virus.
So we talk about in our prostate talk is that natural enters receptor blockers have been found to be endographies, eG, CG and polmeno.
And I'm not going to share the data on that.
If you go to our videos on prostate cancer, you'll see I pull up a whole bunch of research article that natural AR3 blockers are these substances.
So these products endographies, which has been known to be a wonderful antiviral for hundreds of years.
Now they're talking about the possible mechanism of the antiviral benefits of endographies and great TX tract, the Catech and EG, CG from great TX tract, is because it blocks that energy receptor, which tends to be the hijacked receptor.
The hijacked receptor that the virus uses to enter the cells, so that's a great thing.
So using these type of products may prove beneficial in our viral season to help boost our immunity, yes, but they boost our immunity block in the receptors that the virus hijacks to get into the cells.
This is our actual AR blockers endographies, eG, CG, so polmeno.
Our prostate health has so polmeno in it.
Our eG, CG is the TVGO.
The viral clear has endographies, has some other good antivirals in it.
And the clear immunoplus has endographies in it as well.
It has a whole bunch of mushrooms and a whole bunch of other good immune boosters in there.
So we've created an adult immune bundle, and it includes the clear immunoplus, and it includes our new product, the hersolic acid product, and it includes our viral clear product.
That will give people a pretty good boost to their immune system to help prevent from viruses, bacteria, colds, flus, things like that.
It's a great thing that I'll be taking all of those.
And we're going to offer this as a bundle on our site and give everybody a 10% off.
It is really not even expensive. I think the whole bundle comes for $115.
And certainly could be, this is going to be more than a month on this, but it would be a month's supply of both of those, so it's a pretty good deal on that.
Other anons you could take up is lipo with a vitamin C.
This product unfortunately is just harder and harder to find lipo with a vitamin C because there was a couple articles that came out that vitamin C is a great thing for this virus.
I certainly boosted your immune system through polysaccharides.
That's the evolved immune and the burberry. The burberry through is just such a great antibacterial and a fungal antiviral as well.
So those would be anons as well, but the main three products would be the top ones there.
Well, I hope this was beneficial. You got something from it and I tried to break that down as simple as possible.
All right. Thanks so much. Bye-bye.